[Music]
it doesn't know where we're going
we've been keeping it a surprise because
we're doing something really super fun
and exciting this weekend and has no
idea so I've never actually had the
chance to travel somewhere and not know
where I was going so Isaac where do you
think we're going we saw all these guys
in so far where the York regard New York
the weather last few days but we already
planned for this trip so we're like
alright I think you're gonna have to
wear this mask where we're traveling
cause we're on to getting other people
sick
and now he's wearing this black mask you
look at videos I'll show your mess you
know ninjas actually don't make any
noise that's why they're ninjas deadly
assassins hey yeah but it's not as fun
you don't make noises huh
yogi England's guys would be whether a
lot - we've got a note for that
issues I couldn't I wouldn't even see it
or like three it's so excited
really would you believe it like where
we going I just don't know
no one of these he knows that we're gone
for three days has to be something like
sure somewhere close but then you're
smart I thought was 10 years ago we're
gonna figure that out on my own
all right three days is a long time
could be anywhere
Mars really here that down you're pretty
dumb
[Music]
this trip is also kind of like a
precursor warm-up trip to the trip I'm
calling it
that trip you know what's the difference
between thousand P cuz you're
emphasizing that so it turns into like
the trip I don't know the trip anyways
the trip the trip the same thing three
are gonna be going to Morocco very very
soon and this little trip this little
surprise for Isaac is kind of like a
little precursor no no it's not working
and so one of the main objectives of
this trip because Isaac is sick is for
me and TIFF not to get sick because that
big trip to Morocco is less than a week
away if we start getting sick now we're
definitely gonna be sick on that trip
and that's not gonna be any fun but at
least for you at this trip you're you're
getting better people come on no why why
are you gonna get my hopes up like that
hey whatever
[Music]
did you figure out everybody I've begun
regular Alaska he said we're going to
Alaska he's figured it out Alaska
Airlines that's Borelli
really
very smart
[Music]
oh nice I've got a luggage train sorry I
said you weren't part of the party train
we are going to really really good ghost
ridin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so we just got to our hotel and the
front desk guy asked what did he ask us
because he got another clue as to why
we're here
you got another oh so a Disney Pixar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good an apartment so if I open this bag
you will see why we're here
you want to wait until Monday because
today's Saturday or do you want to do
you want to just find out now cuz it's
gonna surprise every step of the way
it's like the matrix is like the matrix
you're the blue pill so do you want to
take the red pill matrix
yeah no no wait Gary took it you just
take it right now you're so you're
probably still might not know exactly
why but ready open it incredible - oh we
got incredible dirt and we rinse them
with Cisco what why do you think we even
watch the movie close your pretty close
actually I don't even know if you're
gonna get to watch the movie but we're
here because they invited us out to test
out the Incredibles - lego video game
what yeah you're a game you're a game
tester oh yeah we're gonna be at Pixar I
know I was so excited for you you're
you're definitely way more excited
Incredibles day Isaac screaming - he's
screaming in his heart yeah it's exactly
have you got a blanket Puckett's oh it's
like a poncho
[Music]
no we did not know which way you what
have you ever had oysters before what'd
you think of that what do you what did
you think of it dance you didn't like it
then now you're 10
within what it tastes like why me why me
[Music]
is it a good or dad or like that's it
good oh we should have ordered more than
I think so too
Frankie I know oh why are you getting so
expensive
[Music]
[Music]
why is it so cold there's people like in
t-shirts and stuff here they must be
from like Russia
[Music]
you finally see the Golden Gate Bridge
in your recent memory yes you don't
remember something when I brought you in
you're a little mom so I brought you
here when you're about like three years
old I think you remember you were in
your stroller I walked you through the
actual ribs on your stroller maybe this
was real maybe this evening
I did read somewhere over there we're in
the house and it was like three minutes
drive away
and you can see the bridge oh yeah
that's definitely a dream baby it's so
beautiful
skip you silly but yeah okay now we're
going to try to walk the bridge
[Music]
[Music]
good morning 7:00 a.m. oh my I locked my
7:00 a.m. at the alarm yeah we're up
right and early because today's the day
whole reason why we're here it's
Incredibles day we get to check out the
new Lego Disney Pixar's the Incredibles
video game I'm so excited I can't wait
Isaac's way too tired he's still trying
to wake up yeah we had a bit of a scare
last night - because TIFF and I thought
you were all getting sick
oh four more days we go on that big trip
so fingers crossed let's we should we
should drink like green tea today they
have it at the campus Pixar campus its
Pixar they gotta have like over there
why do we have the bag so we have the
bag because inside of the bag is smart
so today it's a Monday right it's
technically a school day Disney requires
him to have schooling by like a state
approved teacher something for a few
hours so I'm like that's so cool you're
like a Disney kid like a Disney those
Disney actors yeah because he has to
attend school today whether he likes it
or not that's pretty cool there's a
price to pay when you come visit the
Pixar campus how you feelin Isaac
[Applause]
you're annoyed of me asking me if you're
excited because you just don't look
excited
sometime so like either no are you
excited yes
it's cold
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's so many loggers here most iconic
theme from Pixar guys
what does it feel like
[Music]
I wish our check takes all right so
what's it like to finally be here at the
Pixar studio and see everything in front
of you
[Applause]
my childhood like dream come true
because I remember is seeing things like
you know TV special - whatever about
Pixar off the bazaar and to actually be
here it's pretty
we were you would have on this but we
were up there
and they're like getting to the
classroom where Isaac's studying right
now with the teacher is they just have
all these Pixar Coco
like the sketches or like the clay lobby
original like ideas like concept party
yeah exactly everything that
[Applause]
to create the movie
Isaac's teacher was saying that she
worked on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we just had trivia game inside the
theater behind me where we
peace
the producers even Brad Bird the
director that was so
Mandana worked up Isaac he's bluffing in
it
Oh perfect good isn't he just ninja mess
alright so what are we doing now
[Music]
[Applause]
basketball a go
team members great power three power
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
we talked about the fact that you
thought that three seagulls that might
be I thought they should Mike Mike Mike
I thought it was in correlation with
monsters a Mike Wazowski but I guess not
[Applause]
that makes a lot more sense you're so
smart
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
QT stay hydrated you know we gotta fight
this sickness that's coming about
[Applause]
alright so Isaac you get to play the
game which other leg again
the whole lineup see I head up the
design so cool I think it's to get a
first look at a video game is as a kid I
would go crazy if I ever had the
opportunity to play right next to game
developer
they call a Twinkie
to win in each level it's so awesome I
don't your childhood
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Isak what's it like to gain tests or
like to get a sneak peek of this game oh
yeah
it does huh what's the Isaac preview how
does how does this game compared to all
the other Lego games okay it's more open
what do you mean there's a whole bigger
map five story oh it's a five-star
rating
at this honest review what are you doing
Isaac making it a superhero
[Music]
[Applause]
what do you call him yeah it has its
legal name there amazing you can't have
a legal name you're gonna have a super
name yes
[Applause]
super job Super Snake
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so we are trying to leave the
event was amazing
now we have a problem and I know what
you're thinking you're probably saying
like well you know you didn't have to
take all of it but I was thinking of
baby tiger baby Leia and like our
friends that have kids that will enjoy
this stuff so I was thinking about that
I'm like we'll make it work
so now I'm like uh kind of make it work
all right what do we got we got this set
that I tried unboxing you got another
one of them that's true
you really can't and the backpacks the
backpacks came with stuff inside that's
the house we couldn't even use the
backpacks to fill anything with it's
Christmas incredible edition and I also
have Dukey news tomorrow which I have
not prepared for
so my stress level is up to like right
here
[Applause]
honey I don't know how you did it but
you did it you know you know all that
gear went all the way in here and that's
all the space we saved pure packaging
here pure pure packaging pure packaging
this is pure packaging this is a
friendly packaging yeah look I want to
show them how I did it I'm pretty proud
of this so funny because Isaac had to do
this reading log and he brought like the
fattest book we have at home that's so
funny
he was like oh well actually I could
have brought the Goblet of Fire huh
which is much thinner bigger bigger
yeah we're able to take out all the toys
from the packaging from all that there's
the more in here I like how you're
wearing an Incredibles t-shirt right now
because right now you you're like a
superhero but that's your superpower
Tetris mom anything in the world but I'm
great at organizing and Tetris style of
[Music]